>>Falling.
>>All the way.
>>Narrator: Learning to
support and be supported
by their classmates is a key
lesson for incoming freshman
at East High School
in Anchorage, Alaska.
>>I trust you guys.
>>Teacher: What's your name?
>>Dustin.
>>Narrator: A lesson they
will be tested on every day.
>>All right, I'm falling.
>>Okay, Dustin.
>>Narrator: Led by seniors,
this day-long series of games,
trust exercises and truth
telling sessions is called,
"Change of Heart."
>>Some people think that I'm
gay because I like to dress up.
But I didn't-- being
in middle school,
I didn't knew how to handle it.
But I learned how to
deal with people.
>>Narrator: Designed to
forge a caring community
from the diverse group of 2,400
students and staff at East,
this day is just part of a concerted
effort to address the social
and emotional needs of every
student in the district.
>>Teacher: If you've been
hurt, move into the circle.
>>Narrator: An effort
that began with schools
in turmoil just a few years ago.
>>Alivia: You know, you
hear the horror stories
about like thugs showing
up at school, and like,
you having to look
behind your shoulder.
And that's how it was.
There was a lock-down at lunch.
>>Carol: Alaska, unfortunately,
has the highest rate
of domestic violence,
sexual and child abuse
in the nation, per capita.
And so a lot of our kids, they're
watching violence in their homes,
sometimes they're the ones
being attacked and abused.
And for them to be able to come
into school, which is, frankly,
for many of them their safe haven,
and to automatically switch that off
and say, "Oh, yes, I'm
going to really focus
on algebra," it isn't even realistic.
And so we've got a lot of young
people in very great distress.
>>Narrator: After nearly a
decade of studying best practices
from around the country, the district
adopted concrete standards for social
and emotional knowledge
and appropriate behavior
at every grade level.
They designed classes
to teach specific skills
and develop guidelines
for assessment.
>>Victoria: Any district you
go to probably will have sort
of a left-side of the
report card that has sort
of a checklist of behaviors.
Like responsibility,
citizenship, that sort of thing.
But in a way, that turns into
sort of a meaningless checklist.
How can you offer grades
for something
that you've never addressed?
>>Teacher: We've asked you to
come up with some attitudes
that support your success.
>>Victoria: So we're placing those
with the social/emotional standards,
and giving people ways to
say, "This is the behavior
that you should see
at this grade level."
>>Narrator: Former classroom
teacher, Vicki Blakeney was hired
to coordinate the district's
social/emotional learning
and objectives.
>>Victoria: And asked if
I would use some lessons
and model what they're doing here.
>>Carol: Good.
>>Victoria: I'm a Curriculum
Coordinator.
So I am seen in the same office
as the Language Arts Coordinator,
the Math Coordinator, the
Health Coordinator, etcetera.
To show just visually, politically,
everything else, that we are going
to value this like we value
any of our other curriculum.
>>Teacher: In this bag are
slips of paper that have things
that kids come to school
with, baggage.
Okay? And what I want you to do
is write about some suggestions
that you have so that kids can
let go of some of the baggage
that they're coming to school with.
>>Victoria: A lot of my job as a
Curriculum Coordinator is to look
at the already adopted curriculum.
>>I thought "physical bullying."
>>Victoria: And so,
"Okay, here's a place
where if I was teaching
this reading lesson,
I could also hit this
social/emotional learning center
at the same time."
>>Teacher: "Two roads
diverged in a wood, And I,
I took the one less traveled by, and
that has made all the difference."
What do you think he's saying there?
>>I think he took the one
that not everybody was doing.
Like maybe everybody was doing a
different thing, and he thought
that it was wrong, so
he did the other thing.
And maybe he was right.
>>Teacher: Doesn't have
to be right or wrong.
Just follow your heart.
Be true to yourself.
Look at the poster back there, "What
is popular is not always right;
what is right is not always popular."
>>So Mike has eight
doll-- is this Mike?
>>Narrator: In this
fifth grade math class,
solving problems is
a social activity.
>>Mike started with eight.
Kelly had twice as much
as Mike, and Joe had half
as much as Kelly, which is...
>>Chris: Every teacher out there has
probably said at some point in time,
"Turn to your neighbor
and talk about this idea.
Look at your teammates
and talk about this idea."
>>Why did you do those shapes there?
>>Because it looks cool.
<laughter>
>>Chris: And really watch, if
they are talking about "the topic"
that you've asked them to talk
about, if they're actually listening
to each other and using that
language and those social skills,
then all of a sudden,
you have an environment
where 30 kids are all
learning at the same time.
>>Teacher: Today, Lucia intentionally
bumps into Jackson in the lunchroom
and makes him spill his food.
Then Lucia and her friends
stood back and laughed.
Okay, what are some impulsive
hot-headed thoughts Jackson may
be having?
>>He could have hit her.
>>Teacher: Okay, he
could have hit her.
>>Narrator: The Aggressors,
Victims and Bystanders,
or AVB curriculum has
been adopted by all
of the middle schools
in the district.
>>Teacher: What are some of the
cool-headed thoughts he could have?
>>He might think that she likes him,
and that's why she's
being so mean to him.
>>Teacher: Exactly.
I hate to say it, but
sometimes at middle school,
kids do some really weird
things to the kids they like.
>>Narrator: The AVB curriculum
is also taught in special classes
for the large population
of Native Alaskan students.
>>Tina: Do you start
sweating when you're nervous?
I do.
>>Sometimes.
>>Tina: Sometimes?
Okay. That's your body's
natural reaction.
And if somebody's bullying you, "Hey
Taylor, your name is pretty funny!"
Or, "I saw you looking at that
girl on the bus this morning!"
Okay, he's getting embarrassed.
His face is turning red.
He's a good sport.
So there are a lot of...
>>Tina: I'm from rural Alaska myself.
I'm Inupiat Eskimo and so
I can relate to these kids
on a whole different level.
>>Tina: In middle school, we
call it the "think first" model.
When you are getting provoked, or
you feel like provoking somebody,
it's important to stop, and do what?
>>Size up the situation.
>>Good.
>>Tina: The wonderful thing about our
program is we're able to infuse a lot
of the things that they
are already familiar with.
You know, traditional
ways of knowing.
The way that we teach
is very individualized.
>>Victoria: In the Inupiat language
there are 25 words for "snow."
So they can see 25
different kinds of snow,
because they have vocabulary for it.
And I have one word for
"snow" so I see "snow."
It's the same with emotions.
If all you know is anger, and
it's really just an annoyance
or a frustration, but
what you know is anger,
you're going to respond
in anger every time.
Because that's what you know.
So it's important for us to take
it back a step, and say, "Okay,
let's look at what that
feeling really is."
>>Trudy: Today, you're going
to be interviewing one person.
And that one person is also
going to be interviewing you.
And you're going to write
not only facts about them,
but also some perceptions.
>>Narrator: Freshman English
teacher, Trudy Keller,
incorporates social/emotional
learning standards
in her daily lessons.
>>Trudy: "Scrutinized" is a word
that will be on your next quiz.
I want you to really
scrutinize them and think
about your impressions
beyond just what they say.
So it's what they're
like, what they're feeling
that type of thing, okay?
>>Trudy: One of the students
wrote about his partner
that he interviewed, because this
student's parent was a drug addict,
and actually caused a great
deal of turmoil in the family.
And it was actually a student
that he had sort of looked
down on, I think, before.
And at the end he wrote, "I
have a great deal of respect
for what this student
has been through."
>>Do you have a job,
or what's your home...
>>Well, I have a disabled brother,
and I usually take
care of him myself.
>>Trudy: I just think that you need
to be in touch with their feelings,
their emotions, in
order to teach well.
>>I'm usually out skateboarding
if it's not raining.
>>Trudy: When I know what's going on,
and I acknowledge that,
and we deal with it.
Then we can get on to
the job of learning.
>>Janey: Two, three,
[chorus singing].
>>Narrator: Music teacher,
Janey Lidey wrote this song
after participating in the
"Change of Heart" program
with some of her students.
>>Janey: Because we've sung the
"Change of Heart" song as sort
of our theme song for years now, my
kids, I think, really buy into it,
because you know, they're selling
it, and they-- you just embody it.
All of us just need to be
reminded that it's okay to be kind.
And actually, it's becoming
the cool thing to be that way.
>>Michael: We're all under the gun
to improve our test
results, the academics.
But I tell you what, it's a whole
lot more fun to start focusing
on that connection with kids,
and helping people feel
good about where they are.
The other will follow.
Our teachers, I think,
are much happier.
They like their kids.
>>Teacher: Good job, kiddo!
Excellent.
Practice being cool-headed
this weekend!
>>Victoria: The advantage of spending
time doing this is the payoff
in academics.
There's research out now that shows
that kids involved intentional
social/emotional learning programs
like we're trying to do right here,
scored on average, ten percent higher
on their standardized tests.
So what are we giving up?
We're giving up, you
know, higher referrals,
we're giving up violence
in our schools.
What are we getting?
Kids who come to school, because
they want to come to school.
And kids who know how to act
when they get into the schools.
And hopefully, kids who
will go into their futures
with a better chance at success. [choir sings]
>>For more information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.
>>Choir: [song concludes]
[applause and cheers]